[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
de l'éducation tous les mois nous
partons à la rencontre de tous ceux qui
font l'école pour vous faire découvrir
leur méthode et leurs initiatives vous
allez tout savoir grâce à liberté
égalité scolarité et voici tout de suite
le sommaire
que se passe-t-il en France avec les
mathématiques manquent de vocation
mauvais classement international pour se
remonter le moral on s'est intéressé à
ses profs qui s'ingénient à donner à
leurs élèves le goût de l'algèbre et de
la géométrie
[Musique]
lui les maintenons aucun secret pour lui
Hugo duminyle copain a obtenu la
prestigieuse médaille field en 2022
mettait-il le roi des maths à l'école et
qu'elle laisse sa recette à lui pour
faire aimer la matière il nous dit tout
dans mémoire d'école
que font les élèves pendant les temps
d’activité périscolaires réponse avec le
rêve le responsable éducatif ville qui
officie dans certaines écoles primaires
rêves tapent des acronymes qui après
cette émission n'auront plus de secret
pour vous
enfin comment le cinéma est-il entré à
l'école c'est notre retour en archives
[Musique]
la France est-elle fâchée avec les
mathématiques depuis de nombreuses
années nous figurant parmi les mauvais
élèves des classements internationaux et
notre niveau n'a fait que baisser depuis
40 ans alors comment nous réconcilier
avec les maths comment les faire aimer
aux élèves ici au collège Jacques-Yves
Cousteau à Bussy-Saint-Georges en
Seine-et-Marne depuis deux ans l'équipe
pédagogique mise sur l'aspect ludique
pratique mais est-ce que ça marche c'est
ce qu'on va voir
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour
on a pris une brique comme celle-là
je l'ai ouverte
et pour voir quelle est la partie du
papier qui est utilisée cette brique on
s'est demandé est-ce que cette surface
est-ce qu'elle était la plus petite
possible qui pouvait donner un volume de
1 L et on a dit c'était le cylindre et
on a étudié le cylindre effectivement
allez si je prends ainsi le
j'ai une certaine hauteur qui est h les
bases j'ai deux bases
qui sont des disques et le rayon
on va l'appeler RC Lorient
[Musique]
la joie au tableau on est sur des
formules on est un petit peu sur de la
géométrie aussi calculer la surface
c'est ça
d'accord dis-moi on va chercher l'air
ensuite le volume qu'on peut contenir
donc un litre de lait dans une brique
peut être aussi contenu dans un cylindre
mais ça utilise moins de moins de
cartons c'est ça donc ça c'est un impact
écologique
alors Monsieur Miss Moody expliquez-moi
un petit peu sur les trois heures et
demie de cours de mathématiques que vous
dispensez aux classes de troisième
est-ce que ces trois heures et demie
sont toutes axées sur le développement
durable et l'écologie ou c'est une heure
dans la semaine et le reste du temps
c'est plutôt des mathématiques plus
classiques
pour intéresser les élèves il faut
varier les supports varier les méthodes
il faut rendre les mathématiques
vivantes c'est pour son enfant
s'intéresse aux problèmes de la vie de
tous les jours qui touchent tout le
monde
[Musique]
calculer c'est-à-dire que tu remplaces X
au lieu de remplacer par 0,5 tu vas
remplacer X par 100 et tu calcules bravo
donc vous finissez le travail pour la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]
bonjour Valérie bienvenue merci beaucoup
de nous accueillir dans dans ce collège
qui a cette spécificité c'est de mettre
un peu les mathématiques au cœur j'ai
l'impression de l'établissement de votre
de votre envie en tout cas de les rendre
plus ludique plus simple est-ce que
est-ce que je me trompe quand je vous
dis ça alors pas du tout en fait on a
vraiment un plan global mathématique
l'idée c'était de se dire comment je
peux aborder les maths autrement faire
en sorte que les élèves qui sont les
plus en difficulté
ne soit pas dans un sentiment de j'aime
pas les maths pour toute la vie ou c'est
moi contre les maths et c'est pas fait
pour moi et au contraire d'avoir des
leviers qui permettent peut-être de
d'aller chercher des vocations
aussi bien universitaire avec des études
supérieures destinées aux sciences mais
ça peut être aussi sur des mathématiques
plus appliquées vers la voie
professionnelle pour quels résultats en
fait on s'aperçoit qu'on n'a pas
forcément une élévation numérique pour
les élèves les plus en difficulté mais
par contre je reprendrai un des thèmes
qui pour nous est important l'estime de
soi le bien-être
[Musique]
alors cette fois-ci cours de maths mais
en anglais
OK
vous faites l'intégralité du cours de
maths mais en anglais comment est né ce
projet on a commencé à en discuter
l'année dernière avec Monsieur mesmoudi
avec l'idée de décloisonner un petit peu
les matières ça pourra leur servir pour
la suite dans la vraie vie parce que ça
leur donne déjà l'idée qu'ils sont
capables de suivre un cours dans une
autre langue pour quel résultat
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous vous
percevez vous sentez
nous ce qu'on a perçu c'est à la fin du
premier cours qu'on a donné à cette
classe de l'entrain de la part des
élèves de la motivation
[Musique]
alors il y a les cours de maths imposés
dans les emplois du temps et puis il y a
aussi pour les volontaires pour ceux qui
le souhaitent un club de maths
suivez-moi
ce bloc là
ok du coup il faut que je sais pas ce
que tu avais choisi
donc là il faut que tu ailles dans ton
capteur vas-y
voilà c'est ça tu le mets tu le mets là
voilà c'est ça
en
quoi club de maths déjà en premier lieu
déjà s'amuser en faisant des maths
l'objectif c'est de programmer d'accord
programmer des jeux vidéo et donc sans
s'en rendre compte on fait des maths il
y a pas besoin d'être bon maintenant
plus donc ça c'est bien on programme
sans être bon en maths mais on programme
en même temps faire des maths on peut
aller plus loin aussi quoi
salut
alors dites-moi un petit peu qu'est-ce
que vous avez créé là
ok un jeu Dragon Ball Z et alors comment
vous avez fait pour le créer d'abord on
s'est basé sur les déplacements rapides
ok pour s'asseoir réaliste d'accord
après on s'est basé sur les petites
attaques par exemple
corps à corps ok donc qu'est-ce qu'il
peut faire donc ils peuvent donner des
coups de poing comme ça ils peuvent
faire quoi d'autre
et alors pour créer ça vous avez fait
des maths il fallait faire des maths là
c'est x c'est le milieu lol le centre ok
là est situé là c'est y ok
10 à y ça monte la flèche du haut OK
et c'est pareil pour donc c'est comme si
on avait un plan avec avec une abscisse
et une ordonnée c'est ça
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on vous dit moi je veux
devenir créateur de jeux vidéo parfois
vous l'entendez ça j'ai eu des élèves
récemment là ces dernières années qui
violaient même développeurs par exemple
créer des sites Web ou oui
[Musique]
lui relève très largement notre niveau
national en mathématiques Hugo Dumesnil
copain a reçu en 2022 la médaille field
l'équivalent du prix Nobel en
mathématiques alors était-il un petit
génie dès la maternelle a-t-il une idée
bien à lui pour intéresser les élèves à
sa discipline c'est ce qu'on va lui
demander
bonjour Hugo du mini copain bonjour
Merci beaucoup d'accepter de répondre à
nos petites questions est-ce que vous
êtes né avec la bosse des maths non non
clairement pas moi je viens d'une
famille dans senium mon père était prof
de sport ma mère était danseuse puis est
devenue enseignante institutrice et les
mathématiques faisaient pas du tout
partie de notre vie quand on était
enfant quel type d'élèves vous étiez
petit en école primaire j'avais la
chance d'être quelqu'un qui avait des
facilités à l'école mais qui m'ennuyait
pas vraiment j'avais pas ce problème
d'ennui parce que j'avais toujours envie
de maîtriser un peu plus donc j'avais ce
côté là dans toutes les disciplines avec
des réussites on va dire MOF qui varier
en fonction des disciplines
moi les langues par exemple c'était très
difficile pour moi
mais c'était très dur donc c'est pas que
il y avait un succès absolu mais c'est
vrai que j'étais plutôt la réussite et
en plus j'avais pas de problème de du
premier de la classe parce que j'aimais
énormément le sport j'avais plein d'amis
on donc j'ai pas j'ai vécu une une
enfance à l'école très facile je dirais
j'ai j'avais j'ai pas eu de grosses
difficultés comme au collège et au lycée
là c'est vrai que le lycée Louis grand a
été un choc pour moi parce que je me
suis retrouvé en première à être même en
difficulté en mathématiques ce qui
n'avait jamais été le cas avant pour moi
vous avez des photos des photos de cette
époque alors dites-moi là on est entre
classe on se retrouve dans une classe en
fait à lui grand avec spécial en quelque
sorte avec les gens qui étaient les plus
à l'aise en sciences et donc voilà et
donc la première examen de l'année je
fais je sais plus avant avant dernier ou
quelque chose en maths qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et ça m'a demandé un énorme
travail justement pour récupérer de ce
niveau là et puis vous vous en souvenez
encore aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
c'est un moment qui a marqué quand même
votre scolarité parce que et je pense
que c'est aussi quelque chose qui m'aide
énormément dans mon travail de
chercheurs aujourd'hui c'est que ça a
été un échec mais constructif que j'ai à
partir de ça ça m'a fait me rendre
compte de certaines limites en
particulier peut-être justement jusque
là j'avais cette idée que les
mathématiques c'était peut-être un peu
inné j'étais jeune et bête donc mais
naïve je dirais plutôt et là je me rends
compte ok non en fait il faut travailler
c'est du coup c'est pas du tout inné
c'est quelque chose qui s'apprend c'est
quelque chose qui se développe comme
n'importe quel autre
qualité chez l'individu et ça il faut
casser ce message qui je trouve est
extrêmement inhibant de dire soit c'est
déjà fait soit
voilà soit vous l'avez soit vous l'avez
pas il n'y a rien à faire aujourd'hui on
le sait un classement PISA c'est c'est
terrible les élèves français se classent
régulièrement parmi les moins bons
élèves est-ce que vous vous imaginez
comme solution faire des travaux
pratiques finalement de de par exemple
pourquoi il y a travaux pratiques de
physique de biologie de chimie et pas en
maths et ça c'est implémenté
concrètement par les enseignants mais
qui sont parfois un peu obligés de faire
chacun comme ils peuvent la chose qui
est claire pour moi c'est qu'il y a un
travail à faire sur la vision des maths
et des sciences à la fois à l'école mais
aussi hors de l'école c'est à dire ça
prend en compte les élèves les
enseignants les parents d'élèves les
décideurs politiques je veux dire il y a
un moment où il faut qu'on se repose la
question de qu'est-ce qu'on souhaite
pour la science et comment on va se
baser sur le progrès scientifique merci
beaucoup Hugo du Midi
au gré des réformes sur les rythmes
scolaires la ville de Paris a décidé de
conserver la semaine de cinq jours et
propose à tous les élèves parisiens des
tapes des temps d'activités
périscolaires en plus des 24 heures
d'enseignement hebdomadaire de la pause
méridienne à l'étude du soir tous les
temps en dehors de la classe sont pensés
et orchestrées par le rêve le
responsable éducatif ville nous sommes
devant l'école primaire du Château des
Rentiers dans le 13e arrondissement de
Paris et on va se glisser dans une
journée de rêve
[Musique]
le rêve de cette école donc le
responsable éducatif ville la journée
elle commence par quoi la journée
commence par un petit bilan de la
journée les absences les remplacements
et puis je fais un point sur le logiciel
de présence les animateurs à savoir
comment va se passer le service et puis
organiser le service anticiper pour que
ça se passe au mieux possible la
spécificité ici à Paris dans toutes les
écoles parisiennes ce sont les tapes
tout à fait nous on a des temps
d'inquiétés périscolaires le mardi le
vendredi qui sont optionnels pas du tout
obligatoire et surtout financé par la
Mairie de Paris donc c'est gratuit pour
les parents tout à fait et en fait si je
comprends bien c'est une heure et demie
le mardi et 1h30 le vendredi
salut ça va ouais ça va
bon alors aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs
absences on va essayer de on s'organiser
avec Laura voilà on va venir sur le
terrain tout de suite parce que les
enfants sont en train de sortir ok allez
[Musique]
pendant le premier service il y a donc
des enfants qui eux attendent le
deuxième service et vous proposer à ses
élèves là plusieurs plusieurs activités
ils peuvent si j'ai bien compris avoir
un petit temps de détente c'est ça ou
alors maintenant il y a le centre
sociotech dans l'école je vais vous
montrer venez
bonjour
[Musique]
bonjour les enfants
donc là
chaque personnage a une petite bille
aimantée en dessous et on peut déplacer
le personnage avec un D et on l'a dit
toujours à la ludothèque avant la
cantine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc la Régis il est 15h c'est ça c'est
la première activité qu'on va la suivre
c'est quoi
sur l'école intervenant et donc là on du
coup on va dans un centre en fait il
propose du coup un vrai studio radio
dans lequel les enfants vont pouvoir
s'amuser et faire un projet
[Musique]
alors les enfants vous avez tous
remarqué donc la différence avec les
films des frères Lumière c'est donc
qu'il y a un début un milieu et une fin
tout le monde a bien repéré le début au
début c'est jusqu'à quand Armand
jusqu'au tonneau juste très bien donc on
est encore dans le registre du drôle
dans le registre du comique comme
Charlie Chaplin et les frères Lumière je
me permets de vous couper dans cette
atelier cinéma c'est ça quel est
l'objectif de cet atelier l'idée c'est
qu'à la fin du trimestre on sent bon on
puisse souvent en fabriquer un petit
film pour qu'il puisse toucher vraiment
avec leurs mains comment on fait des
films bon ça vous plaît les enfants cet
atelier cinéma
bon tant mieux alors on va vous laisser
continuer
[Musique]
venez voir l'animateur l'animatrice à
chaque fois que vous avez fini un
exercice par exemple
[Musique]
et l'objectif c'est quoi c'est que les
devoirs soient faits à la fin de l'étude
oui
l'opération ou pas
[Musique]
ensuite
donc là la journée est quasiment
terminée
[Musique]
quand l'école fait son cinéma le réseau
canopé a choisi de s'intéresser au 7e
art et à la façon dont il est entré dans
les écoles et vous allez le voir pour
une fois ce n'est pas sous une Jules
Ferry que cela commence
[Musique]
combien de temps a-t-il fallu pour que
l'école rencontre le cinéma 5 minutes
pas tout à fait mais nous ne disposons
que de 180 secondes pour répondre à
cette question nous abuserons donc de
figure bien connues des cinéphiles
l'ellipse l'accélérer et le faux raccord
[Musique]
1895 quand les ouvriers les ouvrières
sortent des usines lumière ce n'est pas
pour aller au cinéma ni à la Sorbonne la
Sorbonne ou le 16 avril de cette même
année a lieu la seconde projection
privée de l'histoire du cinématographe
cette Sorbonne n'est alors qu'un décor
dans la salle il n'y a pas d'étudiants
mais les savants années 20 les Ciné Club
prennent leur essor ils auront une
importance capitale dans l'éducation des
spectateurs certains d'entre eux
deviendront d'ailleurs de grands
cinéaste après la projection les
discussions sont parfois salées
pour tout le monde d'accord des accords
ce qui ne fait pas discussion dans ces
clubs c'est que le cinéma est un art le
dire et le répéter n'est pas suffisant
on est là pour apprendre à regarder
année 30 de janzay les cinéphiles
retiennent qu'il a créé le Festival de
Cannes ce qu'on sait moins c'est qu'il
est aussi le premier à vouloir mettre le
projecteur au milieu de la classe
l'ancêtre du Centre national de
documentation pédagogique CNDP net en
1932 les images projetées intéressent
les pédagogues elles sont jugées
particulièrement utiles pour observer
les libellules les racines carrées et
même la beauté du paysage cette beauté
est difficile
à découvrir admettre elle est paradoxale
1984 ça y est c'est fait les caméras
passent la porte des établissements
scolaires l'option cinéma et
audiovisuelle voit le jour elle figurera
aux épreuves du bac en 1986
fin année 80 les ministères de
l'éducation de la culture et le Centre
national de la cinématographie prépare
un gros coup avec le dispositif qui
deviendra ma classe au cinéma plus de 2
millions d'élèves de la maternelle au
lycée prennent le chemin des salles
Antoine Doisnel n'en reviendrait pas
[Musique]
en 2001 le plan Lang taska renforce la
présence du 7e art au sein des
établissements le CNDP lui édite de
nombreuses ressources pour les
enseignants aujourd'hui l'importance du
cinéma à l'école est régulièrement
réaffirmée on passe d'un cours de maths
à une projection de psychose on fait de
l'histoire en analysant les 400 coups et
petit à petit les spectateurs de demain
aiguisent leur regard pratique et
acquièrent compétences des savoirs ils
prennent en main les outils et
découvrent les cinématographies du monde
entier
plus que jamais les images sont partout
elles se font transportables les poches
en sont pleines les yeux en viennent à
déborder
aussi est-il toujours plus urgent de
faire prendre conscience aux élèves ce
qu'un travelling peut vouloir dire ce
qu'un son peut évoquer et ce qu'un
raccord peut engendrer
sans toutefois leur faire oublier qu'au
cinéma on peut toujours rêver
[Musique]
la prochaine émission sera sur la caméra
et voilà l'émission est déjà terminée
mais nous on se retrouve très vite sur
SCP
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]